ouais 717 je vous présentons et 7000
milles 1 117 ssf le vrai l'unique la
légende les mains moites carré beaucoup
serge est notre toute nouvelle recrue
dit il me rappelle louis à 30 ans
commence à porter immédiatement on à
fait bienvenue monsieur présent suit la
charge et ayant tél c'est un plaisir
pour la clientèle de vos avoirs pichard
j allais prendre mon slip de bain qui ne
manquait rien maintenant non voulez-vous
que je vous réserve une table pour ce
soir ma foi ce serait impossible à
coleman ont installé un nouveau deal en
dehors ce soir peut-être que bientôt
nous convient
sur cousin qu'est ce que c'est que ce
foutoir
du plaisir féminin bien dormi comme un
bébé et vous comme adam
hubert n'êtes vous pas le meilleur je
répondrais oui ce serait de la
prétention je vous répondrais non ça
serait la bêtise
que savez vous de l'afrique
les africains sont joyeux sympathique
rigolard ce sont nos amis ce sont nos
frères quasiment et ensuite nous
exploitons là bas les mines de diamants
les puits de pétrole le gaz l'uranium
nos amis africains sont très tendues
pour le réussir
ils se sont pas respectées ni traiter
d'égal aig bonjour monsieur ou madame
est ce que vous faites là je pense que
vos valises
c'est mon travail mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ces préjugés rassuré le
président mes respects monsieur le
président hu d'ami
j'aime la france et votre musique c'est
quand même autre chose que cette entame
insupportable je sens qu'on va bien
s'entendre
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas entendu et sont
susceptibles et et il faut prendre des
gants à à qui ça ils comptent sur vous
une heure aucun malentendu je n'ai pas
en ce moment à y voit du racisme partout
vous faites ceci en france maintenant il
ya beaucoup moins de noirs ici et c'est
dommage d'ailleurs